we're now going to talk about
composition of linear functions we'll
see that that gives yet another
interpretation of matrix multiplication
so let's suppose a is an m by p matrix
and b
is p by n so these are two matrices
um of course i can multiply i can form
the product c
equals a b so let's define a function
f and it's going to map rp to rm
and that means that f takes in a p
vector and and returns
an m vector g is going to be a function
that takes in an
n vector and then spits out a p
vector um and these are going to be
defined
by well matrix multiplication by a and b
respectively so
um f uh takes an argument u
which is a p vector and it what it gives
as a result is a u
the matrix a g takes in um
a vector v which is an n vector
and what it gives back is b times f the
matrix vector product these are linear
functions right because they're given by
matrix vector multiplication
now the composition of the two functions
uh
oh some people call it chain is another
one but composition is a standard
mathematical term
that's a function that says basically
take the output
of g and plug it into the input of f so
that's informally now what that means is
this
um this says we're going to define h and
so h
let's see g maps n vectors
and vectors uh to p vectors then f
maps p vectors to m vectors and so we
can we can do g first then
f and that would map something an n
vector to an
m vector okay and so the way we write
that is this is we say h of x
h here is the composition of f and g
and it says h of x is f of g of x now
you really have to sit here and parse
this very carefully to make sure to make
absolute certain that the syntax makes
sense and everything like that so
here x is an n vector g of x
is a i'm going slow to make sure i get
it right it's a p
vector then we look at f and so in
computer science you'd say we checked
the signature of f
but this is math not computer science so
we check we check
what f takes as an input f takes as an
input
indeed a p vector so we're cool and then
f
of g of x is indeed an m vector okay
so uh by the way another notation for
this is h
equals f and a little circle g so that's
another
that's a circle that's not the letter o
um
it's a it's a little circle so f
composed with g
okay now let's figure out what this
composition function is well h of
x is f of g of x and that's so f
to take f of anything you simply
multiply by the matrix a so we put a
there
g of x is indeed bx so it's a
for n time b x
but as you know these this is a this is
like a matrix triple product if we think
of x as a matrix
and it is associative and that means
that i can multiply a
and b together and so what we see is so
what we've shown here
is very cool it says that if you compose
two
linear functions the result is linear
and not only that
the associate matrix is the product of
the matrices associated with each of the
functions
so that's another interpretation um
oh one one thing i should note here is
is very uh is a bit i should note this
and i'll i'll i'll say it
um so basically it says matrix
multiplication is is composition of
linear functions there is one
a weird thing here and i i thought i
would i'd mention it
um and that is that when you see the
product a b
um like that uh what what you have to
you know bear in mind is that b
is first okay it doesn't it looks like
it's second when you write a
b looks like b but b
is first and the reason is that thing
multiplies a vector and the first thing
to touch the vector
roughly speaking is b so b comes first
uh
so it just means that it's a little bit
backwards and you get used to it and
then
everything is is is fine
okay so let's look at an example and an
example
is we're going to we're going to start
from an example we saw a few
lectures ago a few chapters ago which
was on the difference matrix so
now remember that dn is this n minus 1
by
n difference matrix and here it is what
it does
is it produces when you multiply this
matrix by a vector
what you get is the vector of first
differences so it's the second minus the
first entry the third
minus the second all the way up to the
last minus the penultimate
entry okay so that's the that's that's
called the difference matrix and
you may remember what it looks like it
looks you know like this
it's got each row has a minus one and a
one which by now you should kind of get
makes sense right so if you take this
matrix here
and multiply in your mind by an x you
will see that the first
entry of the prod of the matrix vector
product is indeed x2 minus x1 that's
what this tells you the my the one and
the minus one
okay so um well we also have d
sub n minus one and that is the
difference matrix but it's a different
size it's n minus two
by uh n minus one uh
and what it what it does is it takes uh
it it simply takes the uh it's also the
differences but it's one one dimension
smaller
now i can actually multiply these two
matrices because
let's see i can have dn minus 1
times dn and that's an n minus 2 by n
that's a so-called second difference
matrix right
and what it does is it simply
take it forms the differences of the
vector that's the that's the dn
x it takes the differences and then it
forms the differences of the differences
and when you do that you end up with
something that looks like that and it
this maybe looks familiar to you or
maybe not
it the second difference is actually
something like the first
plus the third entry minus twice
the second entry right so these are the
entries of this uh
if you take the so-called second
difference by the way it's also
something like if you like you can think
of this as a second derivative i mean of
course
these are sequences they're not
continuous functions but they're
they're even finite sequences they're
lists of numbers but of course you if
you want to you could think of it as
you know a um you could certainly think
of this
as a second derivative okay so we'll
call
delta this matrix d n minus one d n and
let's do this for n equals five
so so here it is here is the four by
five
difference matrix uh and what it does it
takes a five vector and it spits back
the four differences the differences
being the second minus the first
you know third minus the second fourth
minus the third and fifth minus
the fourth right so that's what that's
what this one does
then you take those you started with you
started with
a five vector now you got four
differences and now you difference those
and you're going to end up with a three
vector
which is you know the well it's the
second difference minus the first
difference and so on and what you do is
you will simply multiply these two
matrices one is
they're the two different sized uh
difference matrices and you get this
matrix here
and you see that sure enough it's this
thing it's exactly the same thing so
it's very cool it just shows you
uh that you can compose two things um
and it all kind of makes sense
i think let's see i think it makes sense
uh okay actually i think it's wrong
because i think these should all be
pluses
but anyway aside from being from having
a typo in the slides
it kind of makes sense